noticed something interesting recently
try to pay attention there are a number
of significant republican candidates
around the country that would include
blake masters in arizona donald bullduck
in new hampshire for example
who seem to have been defunded by the
republican party in washington
why is that something's going on here
ned ryan might know what is going on
here he's the ceo of american majority
he joins us tonight ned thanks so much
for coming on so
maybe i'm just being paranoid though i'm
not sure you can be too paranoid at this
point but it seems like a lot of the
candidates who are challenging the most
basic orthodoxies of washington views
that are not shared by the majority of
americans people actually want to make
this a representative government are
getting shafted by the funders in dc is
this happening
it's absolutely happening i mean mitch
mcconnell's senate leadership fund just
pulled eight million dollars worth of
ads out of arizona and tucker i remind
people that the emerson poll that just
came out recently shows blake down by
two points
against mark kelly who's only at 47
percent it's an eminent it's it's a
winnable race
and i would i think one of the reasons
they're doing this tucker for being
honest the gop establishment
establishment is not putting america
first they don't want america first it's
washington first and america maybe
eventually
and you look at this this behavior it's
it's by sociopaths you can only look at
this mitch mcconnell
would much rather lose races than have
america first senators in the senate
because he's petty he's vindictive and
he despises the base
and that's the only explanation i think
it's the real explanation as to why he's
pulling funder for funding for blake
masters and others he would prefer to be
in the minority he's playing games
tucker let's be clear he's playing games
with the future of this country because
he is petty and vindictive
well it's also true at least according
to news accounts that mitch mcconnell's
family has benefited greatly from its
ties to china communist china so maybe
it wouldn't be a good thing to have
other members of the senate who are
openly anti-china who might say
something like that out loud because
you're not allowed to say that out loud
well i mean it's a problem you don't
want america first senators inside a
republican caucus then it becomes unruly
you might not be able to control it
i've said this plenty of times tucker
i'll say it again mitch mcconnell is a
small enough individual
that when push comes to shove all he
really cares about is being the leader
of the republican caucus even if he's in
the minority that's all that mitch
mcconnell cares about he doesn't care
about being really being in the majority
he doesn't care about the country he
wants to be the leader of the republican
caucus inside of the senate and if he
has america first senators inside of the
caucus it becomes problematic for him
therefore i will pull funding eight
million worth from blake masters and
other funding from other america first
types because i'd much rather they lose
than win and cause problems for me in
washington dc even if it means i'm in
the majority
man i hope patriotic americans can make
up that deficit and get blake masters to
the united states senate where he can
help clean the house i really do i
really hope i'm here
ned ryan thank you so much for that
analysis
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight